За останні два роки українці значно більше стали літати по країні.
За даними міністерства інфраструктури України, у 2017 році кількість перевезених пасажирів
збільшилась порівняно з попереднім роком майже на третину.
Переважна більшість людей подорожує всередині України
з наміром далі летіти на міжнародних рейсах.
Передусім цим зумовлений розвиток ринку внутрішніх перевезень.
Пасажир в Україні з'явився.
І його здатність оплачувати повітряні перевезення зростає.
І, крім того, є фактор безвізового режиму, і він насправді дуже суттєво впливає.
Якщо взяти аеропорт Жуляни, ви побачите до 60 відсотків зростання перевезень
після введення безвізового режиму.
Тобто з'являються нові авіакомпанії або нарощуються можливості вже існуючих.
Регулярні внутрішні пасажирські перевезення між 9 містами України
минулоріч виконували п'ять вітчизняних авіакомпаній:
перевезено понад 930 тисяч пасажирів.
За словами генерального директора авіакомпанії "Windrose" Володимира Каменчука,
переважну більшість внутрішніх рейсів в Україні виконує авіакомпанія МАУ,
яка використовує літаки Боїнг-737 та Ембраєр-190.
В Авіакомпанії "Мотор Січ" - літаки Ан-140, Ан-24 та Як-40.
Деякі з них зроблені у 60-х роках минулого століття.
За даними avianews.com, середній вік парку цивільних авіамашин в Україні
наближається до 19 років.
В Україні зберігається так звана перша категорія авіаційної безпеки.
Це означає, що будь-який літак, який має український сертифікат льотної придатності,
перевіряється точно за такими самими правилами і нормами, як, наприклад, європейський літак.
Наприклад, на п'ятому році літак проходить так званий "Сі чек",
це означає такі категорії, коли літак буквально розбирають по гвинтиках і збирають назад.
Якщо там десь щось перержавіло - воно замінюється.
В найкращому стані перебувають аеропорти Бориспіль, Жуляни, Львів, Харків,
зазначають авіаексперти.
Міністерство інфраструктури у своїй стратегії вказує,
що кожна область в Україні повинна мати свій аеропорт,
який прийматиме не тільки внутрішні, але й міжнародні рейси.
Утім, до цього Україні ще далеко.
Все пояснюється ціною на квитки.
Наприклад, найдешевший переліт 3 серпня з Києва до Запоріжжя коштуватиме 3589 гривень,
що практично дорівнює мінімальній зарплатні в Україні.
Тим часом найдорожчий квиток на потязі Інтерсіті на ту ж дату коштує 773 гривні, а є і за 140.
Авіакомпаніям поки невигідно скидати ціну.
А залізниця, що дотується державою, має можливість тримати низькі ціни на квитки.